both of us are probably going to be
working our whole lives from being known
as the kardashians little sisters
i am kim kardashian i am fabulous and i
am the best and everyone does
what i say and soon i'll be the queen of
the world
you're my favorite daughter thanks mom
to supermodel and billionaire makeup
mogul
i don't feel any different but
it's it's fun kendall and kylie jenner
have both proven that they can
rise and shine all on their own rise and
shine
but before all their successes the
youngest gender siblings were just
kids growing up in the famous family
spotlight so this is the little one this
is
kendall jenner this is uh a
five-year-old my five-year-old we have
one younger who's down here kendall
oh she wants to get picked up too okay
so there's the last two jenners right
here
the hair back today sweep these hungry
okay hold on hold on hold on grab with
your legs
no saddle today we're going bareback
guys look over
wave to the camera say goodbye bye bye
we're out of here we're in kimball and
kylie's dollhouse
welcome to their little villa that we
have here at the jenner house huh girls
huh this is where we spend a lot of time
this is like a little oh there goes
kendall upstairs so you'll see her pop
out the top
these are my god children kylie
and they're on the other side of kathy
we're not always proud of them
yes we are kendall and kylie jenner yeah
are you excited about the show
kendall and kylie made their reality
debut on keeping up with the kardashians
at ages 11 and 9 respectively
margarita go go go go go go go go go
go all right shake
[Music]
slip flip
while we're having a party we grew up
like
in this lifestyle like it's kind of it's
normal after a while
right i mean most people might say it's
like that's not normal but it
is for us you know because we've never
known i don't even remember life without
a tv show
fast forward to 2012 kylie and kendall
started dipping their toes in the family
business together
starting with their own fashion line i
think we've definitely always been
interested
watching our sisters and them with their
clothing line going through that entire
process
just growing up in my family i think
especially like my grandmother my mom's
mom
and just my mom and my sisters have
always been so into fashion
so growing up when i did not care about
it when i was like
getting into the show and everything at
like nine years old i would just watch
them
and their style and like ask them
questions and then eventually
i'm stylish we wanted to be us we didn't
want to have
anybody else involved like our sisters
or our mom or anything we wanted to be
our stuff our opinions on everything
no i love kim's style lately is amazing
i feel like kendall's more courtney yeah
yeah i
tend to borrow a lot of her clothes too
so that makes sense kendall and kylie
eventually started focusing on their own
passion projects
first up kendall and her booming
modeling career
walking the runways of the world's
biggest fashion designers
i think being in different cities like
paris and london
and new york and everything you kind of
like i swear my style changes the
different city that i'm in so
it's like i mean you get a taste of
everything and i'm lucky enough to work
with some of the most
creative people in the world a full
circle moment came for kendall in 2015
when she booked her dream job a spot in
the victoria's secret fashion show
it's a full dream come true i really did
not expect me
any time in the near future to ever be
wearing this robe and be in this room so
it's really exciting i watch the shows
every year and to actually be here is
super surreal
meanwhile kylie's pursued her interest
in the beauty business
she saw quick success after launching
her kylie lip kits which sold out within
minutes
the reality star went on to rename the
brand kylie cosmetics
expanding beyond lip kits to create a
full service skin
and beauty line and the rest is history
i like to do stuff that i'm passionate
about
and believe in because if i don't then i
won't be as like
feel involved and like happy about what
i'm doing as kylie heavily relies on her
social media
influence on both snapchat and instagram
it's no surprise within four years
kylie cosmetics hit the one billion
dollar mark
i literally have spent days and weeks of
my time doing this
so and it's stuff that i would never
want to
like choose to share in a million years
but deep down like i would love my true
fans to know
like all my personal stuff and tricks in
2017
forbes listed kendall as the world's
highest paid model
and the following year kylie as the
country's richest
self-made woman to say kris jenner is a
proud mama
is an understatement i'm proud of all my
kids because they really have an amazing
work ethic
and they roll their sleeves up and
really do what they love to do
so that makes me really happy like with
kendall and her modeling she just knew
what she wanted to do
same with kylie and her makeup it's they
all find their passion
and when that happens it's like it's
magical just growing up
in front of the spotlight is extremely
difficult
and you're growing and you're making
mistakes
and everyone's judging you so that's
definitely hard but
there's so many blessings that come
along with it too so
we're grateful for it not much to
complain about i think having so many
people
like love you is such a blessing i don't
know like you wouldn't expect this many
people to like
care about you and want to see you
succeed so i think that that's really
awesome
and we definitely really appreciate it